je m'appelle Turner sake et je viens de Cape
Caution et j'ai 39 ans et moi McIver et
j'ai sculpté toute ma vie depuis que
j'ai 10 euros j'ai appris comment j'ai appris en
regardant mon grand-père qu'il avait l'habitude de
sculpter j'avais l'habitude de  asseyez-vous à côté de lui quand il avait l'
habitude de travailler sur ce carbone et pour
vous en vieillissant quel genre de choses aimiez-
vous sculpter J'aime faire des
sculptures différentes plutôt que de faire la même chose tout
le temps et parfois je suivais simplement
la forme de la pierre  et essayez de ne pas
trop gaspiller Wow alors qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
vous pouvez voir un vous pouvez voir une pierre et
vous pouvez voir une image dans la pierre
avant même de commencer oui pas tout le
temps mais cela arrive généralement et quel
type de pierre fait  vous travaillez le plus
je travaille surtout avec la
stéatite serpentine du collège parlez nous un
peu de vos sculptures qui sont juste
ici chez vous ou vos sculptures excusez moi oui
ces carbones j'aime faire des visages que mon
grand père faisait juste les visages
mais l'idée  est venu est venu que si je fais un
plus de travail que le visage ajoutant une
victoire avec
un exploit combien de temps vous faudrait-il pour
sculpter quelque chose comme nous voyons juste
ici à côté de vous celui-ci ce genre de
paix il faut quatre à cinq jours pour le
terminer à partir de ce moment  comment vous
sentez-vous quand vous sculptez quelque chose comme
ça et comment vous sentez-vous quand vous
avez fini quand ils sont finis je regarde je
regarde de plus près quand je regarde de plus près
quand j'ai l'air de regarder les détails que
j'ai fait  Je n'ai pas besoin de travailler un peu plus, mais
quand c'est complètement terminé, je me sens soulagé
et cela parce que vous
travaillez dur et que vous utilisez une machine ou des
outils aujourd'hui, ouais, principalement des outils électriques, des
meuleuses et des meuleuses et d'autres petits
outils électriques, mais je la plupart du temps.  utiliser une
meuleuse et une meuleuse d'angle et des
outils à main comme des ciseaux ou des limes à main J'aimais
vraiment les outils à main
mais cela prend un peu plus de temps pour
finir et les outils électriques sont beaucoup plus jolis plus
rapides aujourd'hui et beaucoup plus faciles à
comprendre  la pierre avec un outil électrique  que
diriez-vous à vos enfants s'ils
veulent être sculpteur comme vous étiez un
artiste les encouragerez-vous ou les
découragerez-vous ouais je les
encouragerais mais j'aimerais les voir
finir la vis en premier parce que je
ne
finis jamais le  l'école, vous serez plus
important s'ils terminent l'école
qu'ils n'auraient pas de mal à
parler ou à parler anglais comme si je
suis cap dorset est célèbre pour le
prince et la collection annuelle d'impressions
pensez-vous que la sculpture devrait
devenir plus  attention qu'ils ne le sont,
nous les Cubs avons besoin de plus d'attention
que de se précipiter aujourd'hui parce que les
jeunes voitures, en particulier aujourd'hui, font un
travail précipité même si nous les
encourageons à prendre leur temps si nous regardons vers l'
avenir, vous savez qu'il y avait le 50e
anniversaire du cap
collection d'imprimés dorset l'année dernière si nous attendons avec impatience
les 50 prochaines années, comment espérez-vous que la
scène artistique ici à Cape Dorset change
pour Carver comme vous, c'est une
bonne question mais oui je w  comme il
continuera à continuer comme il le fait maintenant même
si le temps change aujourd'hui ouais la
vie a changé aujourd'hui qu'avant donc
c'est un peu difficile de prédire plus difficile
de dire à mon rush rush ce que je peux
voir et ensuite savoir est là  toute
autre chose que vous voudriez que les gens qui regardent
ceci sachent sur vous votre vie à Cape
Dorset ou votre travail en tant que sculpteur, les
voitures plus jeunes peuvent écouter davantage et respecter
l'aîné
et de cette façon, elles ne perdraient pas vraiment à
faire des sculptures comme aujourd'hui ouais je
ce que je faisais s'ils pouvaient écouter et je suis sûr
qu'ils pouvaient écouter et un jour je voulais les
encourager davantage et partager davantage avec eux
comment l'œuvre d'art le carbone
au-dessus du carbone cela fonctionne ou comment cela
fonctionne sans se précipiter sans se précipiter
Turner merci beaucoup, tout simplement génial,
vous travaillez rapidement